Pete Davidson grew from an exceptionally
challenging childhood to an adult life
marred by public scrutiny. From periods in rehab
to struggles with physical and mental disorders,
these are the tragic details of Davidson's life.
Pete Davidson's early life was marred by
trauma in a way that few other people ever
experience. When he was only 7 years
old, his father was killed during the
September 11 attacks in New York. Scott
Matthew Davidson was a firefighter in the
city and was part of the response team
that attended the World Trade Center.
According to eyewitness accounts, Scott
was last seen running up the stairs
of the Marriott World Trade Center hotel
moments before the Twin Towers collapsed,
completely destroying the building and
killing almost everyone who was inside.
Scott, who graduated from the fire
academy in 1994 before joining Ladder
Company 118 in Brooklyn Heights, had always
dreamed of being a firefighter. He was 33
years old at the time of his death. Pete
remembers him with a tattoo on his left
arm of his father's badge number alongside a
replica of the helmet he wore while on duty.
Scott's influence may well have been
a significant factor in Pete becoming
a comedian as an adult. As an old schoolmate of
the fallen fighter recalled to the New York Post,
"Scott was always clowning around.
Telling jokes, making people laugh."
Despite the tragic nature of his father's
death, Davidson has dealt with the loss
with strength, even making jokes about
his father's passing when appropriate.
Considering the traumatic loss of
his father, it's not surprising
that Davidson didn't have the perfect
childhood. The death of his father in
such a shocking way was overwhelming
for the young boy, and his mother,
Amy Davidson, told the New York Times that
the future-comedian's upbringing was very sad.
According to the outlet, Davidson
attended three different high
schools due to conflicts with other
students and his own bad behavior.
He even pulled out his own hair as
a result of his emotional turmoil.
He eventually came to realize that the problem
wasn't other kids — it was him. Speaking on
Peacock's talk show Hart to Heart, Davidson
explained that it wasn't just his father's
death that negatively affected his childhood. The
fact that his mother was a single parent and he
had a very young sister also had an effect on him
despite his family being loving and supportive.
“Single mom, like, new sister. Just
like, did not handle it great."
It may seem odd, but Pete Davidson credits
Kid Cudi with saving his life as a child. His
mental health issues led to the youngster having
suicidal thoughts, and the comedian has since
admitted that he believes that he may well have
ended his own life if it wasn't for the rapper
and singer. In particular, Davidson says that
the 2009 album Man on the Moon: The End of Day
saved his life. He confirmed this in an interview
with Power 105.1's The Breakfast Club, saying,
"I would've killed myself. Absolutely.
100 percent. I truly believe if Man on
the Moon didn't come out, I wouldn't be here."
The comedian said the emotional nature of Kid
Cudi's music struck a chord with him and many
other young people. In recent years, Kid Cudi has
spoken out about his own mental health problems,
with the musician entering rehab
for depression in 2016. As an adult,
Davidson has even gotten to work with
his idol, and he continues to appreciate
that Kid Cudi was willing to speak so
openly about his personal experiences.
Davidson was first diagnosed with Crohn's
disease when he was still a teenager. Crohn's
disease is a condition where parts of
the digestive system become inflamed,
causing a variety of painful symptoms, such
as diarrhea, stomach cramps, and fatigue.
Once diagnosed, Crohn's disease is not curable;
patients live with it for the rest of their
lives. However, available treatments can help
manage symptoms and allow those living with
the disease to live relatively normal lives.
Treatments include medicines to help
alleviate symptoms and also surgery to
remove small parts of the digestive system that
become particularly inflamed during flare-ups.
The unpredictable nature of the condition means
that it can be challenging to live with as it is
impossible to know exactly when the symptoms
will occur. Davidson has been open about how
the condition affects him, telling High Times
that the disease would cause him so much pain
he couldn't eat. However, he found that smoking
cannabis proved a reliable solution to this issue.
"Then I'd smoke and I'd be able
to eat and be able to do my shows,
and I wouldn't be able to do
SNL if I didn't smoke weed."
Davidson has also spoken openly about
having borderline personality disorder.
This is a condition that affects
a person's thoughts and emotions,
as well as their ability to
communicate with other people.
Those living with the condition will often
act in a rash manner without considering the
consequences and also have trouble controlling
their emotions. Exactly what causes borderline
personality disorder is unclear, although
it has been linked with traumatic events.
Davidson first revealed the diagnosis
during the film King of Staten Island,
and has often talked about how he struggles
with regular bouts of depression. He later
said on the WTF With Marc Maron podcast that he
would have, quote, "mental breakdowns" where he
would spiral into a rage and not remember.
To spread awareness about mental health,
the comedian spoke up during a feature on SNL's
"Weekend Update" segment, urging viewers who
may be suffering with depression or similar
conditions to talk to doctors and seek help.
"First of all, if you think you're depressed,
you know, see a doctor and talk to them
about medication and also be healthy."
The former SNL star has regularly checked
into rehabilitation facilities to help
address his mental health. Most recently,
he entered a rehab center in Pennsylvania
in 2023 for in-patient therapy as a
result of his borderline personality
disorder and post-traumatic stress syndrome. As
a source close to Davidson confirmed to People,
"Pete will often check himself into
rehab to work on these issues."
As someone who has not been afraid to share
sensitive details of his personal life,
it is not particularly surprising that Pete
Davidson has been open about his addictions.
As a way of self-medicating, Davidson frequently
smokes cannabis and spent two stints in rehab
facilities trying to deal with his use of the
drug after blaming it for intense mood swings.
Over the course of his career, Davidson
has spent time in and out of rehab,
even spending a period completely free of drugs
and alcohol. As he wrote in a 2017 Instagram post,
"I quit drugs and am happy and sober for
the first time in 8 years. It wasn't easy,
but I got a great girl, great friends
and I consider myself a lucky man."
However, his sobriety didn't last long, and a
year later he was smoking and drinking again.
Cannabis is not the only drug that has landed
him in rehab, either. According to People,
during a comedy show with John Mulaney
and Jon Stewart in September 2023,
he revealed that he had been
taking ketamine every day for
four years before going to a rehabilitation
facility. He even joked to the audience,
"I got that post-rehab glow.
Seventh time's the charm!"
Like many other edgy comedians, Davidson
is no stranger to controversy and has
often faced criticism for many of his
jokes. During an SNL sketch in 2019,
he compared the Catholic Church to musician R.
Kelly after the latter had been convicted for
crimes relating to child sex abuse. The year
prior, the Roman Catholic Diocese of Brooklyn
had agreed to pay millions to settle a
lawsuit alleging sexual misconduct. The
same diocese demanded an apology from the
show and Davidson in response to the joke.
His Netflix special, Pete Davidson
Presents: Alive From New York,
also drew condemnation from many people within
the gay community for what were perceived to
be homophobic jokes. More recently, the
Netflix special Pete Davidson Presents:
The Best Friends also caused controversy for
jokes referencing AIDS and Jeffrey Epstein.
The comedian also famously apologized to
Republican politician Dan Crenshaw
for mocking the eye patch he wears.
"You may be surprised he's a
congressional candidate from Texas,
and not a hitman in a porno movie."
Sadly, Crenshaw wears the eyepatch as a
result of an injury he received while on
active duty in Afghanistan. Even so, Davidson
later retracted his apology to the politician.
In 2018, Davidson caused concern when he
posted a cryptic message on Instagram.
In the wake of his public split with his
ex-fiancée Ariana Grande, Davidson wrote,
"I'm trying to understand how
when something happens to a guy
the whole entire world just trashes him
without any facts or frame of reference."
He also complained that he had
been bullied for nine months,
seemingly in reference to his relationship
with the musician. Several days later,
police performed a welfare check after
Davidson again posted on Instagram,
this time with a message suggesting
he was having suicidal thoughts.
He later deleted his social
media accounts altogether,
further distressing fans. However, he did
continue to appear on Saturday Night Live,
though neither he nor NBC have issued a
statement regarding the posts he made.
With Kim Kardashian being one of the
most well-known people on the planet,
the fact that she was dating Pete Davidson
made headlines around the world. This news
was further heightened due to her recent
split with her ex-husband Kanye West,
who was seemingly unhappy with
the pair seeing each other.
In February 2022, West launched a tirade
against Davidson and even encouraged fans
to verbally harass him in public.
The musician was later banned from
Instagram for 24 hours after making
threatening remarks to both Davidson
and fellow comedian Trevor Noah. West
continued to post about Davidson and
his relationship with Kim Kardashian months
later, even after the pair eventually split.
The negative attention and threats from West
took a toll on Davidson. In August 2022,
it was revealed that the comedian was
in trauma therapy as a result of his
interactions with West. As a source told People,
"The attention and negativity
coming from Kanye and his antics
is a trigger for [Pete], and
he's had to seek out help."
Although they were no longer together,
Kardashian was supportive of Davidson
seeking therapy and criticized
the behavior of her ex-husband.
Davidson was one of the youngest
ever cast members to join SNL,
first appearing on the show when
he was just 20 years old. However,
that doesn't mean that the experience has
always been enjoyable. While he's said he
is thankful for the opportunities it has
given him, Davidson has also spoken out
about how he feels he has been poorly treated
at times by his fellow writers and comedians.
Speaking to Charlamagne Tha God, Davidson revealed
that he doesn't feel like the show has his back,
despite having a strong relationship
with executive producer Lorne Michaels.
Davidson believed that when he wasn't
around, his colleagues and castmates
would talk poorly of him behind his back,
which upset and confused the rising star.
On Jon Bernthal's Real Ones podcast,
Davidson went into more detail about
how jokes about his personal life made
working on the show more difficult. He
explained that there were moments on the show
where a joke would be made at his expense,
and then he'd need to walk onstage to
the derisive laughter of the audience.
He stated that, over time, that began
to take a toll on his own self-image.
"You know, because it seems like
all really talented people are
sick. Don't worry Colin, me and you are good."
Anyone who is familiar with Pete
Davidson will know that he has an
extensive number of tattoos across his
entire body. These range from references
to previous girlfriends to designs by his
friends like Machine Gun Kelly to pieces he
purposefully got while filming a role. The
comedian even has a matching tattoo with
Miley Cyrus as the two appeared in an SNL
sketch together where they played babies.
Davidson has, in recent years, begun to
have many of these tattoos removed. He
explained on Late Night with Seth Meyers
that this was a decision he made because
of his career in Hollywood. It takes
so long to cover up the tattoos when
filming that it made more sense for the
comedian to get rid of them completely.
What many people may not realize, though, is that
one of the reasons that Davidson started getting
tattoos in the first place was to cover up scars
from self-harm. Speaking with Charlamagne tha God,
Davidson noted that some of the tattoos on
his chest specifically are there to hide
scars from cutting himself there.
He also revealed that, at times,
he saw self-harm as his only option
for a release while stressed, saying,
"Whenever you're so manic and upset, sometimes
that's the only thing that will work for me."
Thankfully, Davidson's stints in rehab
have exposed him to healthier coping
mechanisms in situations where
he feels emotionally overwhelmed.